foreign
hello and welcome to gospel Ministries
International my name is Brantley
Greenlaw and with us this week and today
is a guest speaker his name is Elder
Randy skeet Randy thank you so much for
being here my pleasure we have enjoyed
so far the recordings that have been
have been conducted at the Village
Chapel and today we have a special
session with him uh question and answer
is that people have been asking
and these are important questions for
each one of us to hear and to understand
but before we begin eldersky would you
offer a word of prayer surely Our Father
in heaven we need your wisdom to speak
accurately about what your word says
you've promised in James 1 verse 5 if
any of you lack wisdom let him ask of
God grant us that wisdom I pray that the
truth might be made plain and simple
bless all those who listening in Jesus
name amen amen without further Ado let's
let's get into something these questions
the first one is what happens to a man's
Spirit after he dies
what happens to man's Spirit after he
dies is a very very important question
if you look at the way Man was created
mankind Genesis 2 verse 7 the bible says
and the Lord God formed man of the Dust
of the ground breathed into his nostrils
the breath of life and Man became a
living soul and so the physical material
was from the ground and then God
breathed life into that person and some
people call that life the spirit or the
breath that's fine in Genesis 3 verse 17
when God addressed Adam after he had
sinned God said because thou has
hearkened unto the voice of thy wife and
has eaten of the tree of which I
commanded the saying Thou shalt not eat
of it cursed is the ground for thy sake
in sorrow shalt thou eat of it all the
days of thy life Thorns also in thistle
shall it bring forth unto thee and thou
shall eat the herb of the field in the
sweat of thy fish shall thou it bread
till thou return unto the ground for out
of it was thou taken for Dost thou art
and unto thus shall thou return now God
tells Adam you'll go back to the dust
and so the physical part of a person
goes to the dust but the breath the life
the spirit goes back to God because
verse 7 of chapter 2 tells us God formed
him from the dust of the ground that's
from the earth breathe into his nostrils
the breath of life and so we have the
physical material from the Earth where
we have the breath from Above So at
death the breath goes back to its origin
which is God you can call it the life
the physical material decomposes and
becomes dirt again now what goes back to
God is not a Living spirit that floats
around like a ghost it is simply
whatever God breathed into him goes back
to God simple as that
speaking of death
people have a fear of death and so the
question is asked how do I know if I'm
going to be saved
that's a very very very important
question how do I know you know you'll
be saved if your life is given to Christ
one hundred percent
let me say that again
your certainty of salvation is based on
this one
Christ is able to save you two you have
given your life to him entirely so that
he might save you Christ cannot save the
life that is not given to him if you've
given your life to Christ and this
becomes the pattern of your life
continual surrender to Christ you will
be saved whether you feel like it or not
because salvation is not based on how
you feel it is based on the fact that
Christ is able to save you there's
salvation only in Christ he is the
foundation on which our salvation is
based if you have given your life and I
repeat
entirely to Christ you have given your
life to someone who is more than able to
save you so the Assurance of your
salvation lies not in you but it lies in
what Jesus Christ can do he's able to
save to the utmost those who come unto
him by faith and Faith requires total
surrender and that surrender must be a
way of life every day you surrender your
life to Christ the fact that he can save
is your Assurance of your salvation
another question that people have is um
okay that's wonderful but they say I'm a
good person I'm not into drugs I don't
hurt people I care about people why do I
need to go to church why do I need to
participate in this process of being
with other people
again these questions are excellent
Jesus told Peter in Matthew 16 18 and
19. thou art Peter and Upon This Rock I
will build my church
Jesus Christ has a church so when you
are saved Christ leads you to his church
in Acts 7 37 38 when Stephen preached a
very powerful sermon he said Moses was
with the church in the wilderness God
called the Israelites out of Egypt and
formed them into a nation church now why
do I say that in Exodus 19 reading from
verse 4 the Bible says ye have seen what
I did unto Egypt unto Egyptians and how
I bear You On Eagle's Wings and brought
you unto myself now therefore if he will
obey my voice indeed and keep my
Covenant then he shall be a peculiar
treasure unto me above all people and ye
shall be unto me a kingdom of priests
and the holy nation God brought the
Israelites out and at the base of Sinai
he Incorporated them into a nation
Church the entire nation was a church
and the church church was a nation and
so God said if you obey me I will make
you a holy nation and the holy nation is
one that practices Holiness seven days a
week not only on Sabbath and so the
concept of church is very very important
because the church on Earth is founded
by Christ and the constitution of that
church he issued a Sinai his Ten
Commandments and so Jesus says the Gates
of Hell shall not Prevail against my
church in Acts chapter 9 when Christ met
Saul on the road to Damascus and he
knocked him off his horse Saul said to
him and Saul later became Paul Lord what
will thou have me to do and Jesus said
go into the City and it shall be told
thee what thou must do Christ set Paul
to the church at Antioch and the church
told Paul what he should do because the
church had the authority to speak for
Christ Christ could have told Paul right
there on the ground what do you ought to
do but Christ wanted Paul to understand
I have a group on this church that
speaks with authority because they say
what I say and so Jesus sent Paul to the
church and the church told him what he
ought to do it is important to be in
church not any church it's important to
be in the church that obeys and
recognizes the authority of God being in
church is absolutely important because
your adversary the devil as a roaring
lion walketh about seeking whom he made
his he may devour in the natural world a
lion or a cheetah or a leopard when they
choose prey they try to isolate an
animal from the herd once the animal is
isolated it becomes more susceptible to
being attacked this happens spiritually
you probably have felt this way in
church surrounded by fellow believers
who were praying and singing and doing
whatever else there's a feeling of
strength when you are by yourself
ourselves the feeling is slightly
different Christ has a church and it is
important to be part of that church it
is dangerous to just serve God on your
own in an isolated circumstance that
puts you in spiritual Peril it is
important to be part of the church body
okay the next question says but I'm
young and I want to be with my friends
why do I need to go to church I can be
with my friends aren't they my church uh
you know when I get older I'll go ahead
and go to church like everybody else
well that is based on the fact that you
will live long you see there's no
guarantee of long life the Bible says
remember now thy Creator in the days of
the youth Ecclesiastes 12 verse 1 who is
the creator Jesus Christ so the Bible
tells you remember Christ your savior
when you were young and Jesus Christ
says I have a church now if you're
concerned about your friends your
friends the friends you should have are
friends who are part of your spiritual
life in other words friends in the
church because friends in the church are
more likely I say more likely to
influence you the right way and so yes
youth like their friends but all the
people such as I we also like our
friends but your friends primarily
should be members of your spiritual
community and let me stress again Jesus
Christ has a church and that is where
you ought to be that is where your
friends should come from so being young
does not disqualify you for being a
member of the church Timothy in the
Bible Bible scholars believe he was a
teenager when he began to assist Paul
and he began to lead churches as a
teenager Timothy LED churches one of the
safest places if not the safest places
for a young person is the church but I
must stress a church that recognizes the
authority of Christ and obeys him
the next question that we have is
one where it's objective or subjectives
in other words some
what is true for you
may not be true for me so why should I
listen to your version of the truth when
I don't I either don't want to or I
don't think that your version of the
truth is relevant so how do you how do
you answer that question
that's a common modern problem I suspect
it also existed in ages past
the Bible tells us what truth is when
Jesus prayed to his father in John 17 he
said sanctify them through thy truth Thy
word is truth for the Christian this is
the source of Truth this is the the the
the fountain to which you go to drink
the words of life and the words of Life
are the words of truth we cannot have
each person deciding what is truth that
leads to the condition you read about in
the Book of Judges where every man did
that which was right in his own eyes God
does not permit that God has a standard
of Truth and that standard is his word
as a matter of fact the truth is so
important to God that Jesus Christ
himself is called the truth he is called
the word of God Revelation 1913 his name
is called the word of God John 14 6 I am
the way the truth and the life first
John 5 6 The Holy Spirit is truth
Deuteronomy 32 verse 4 the father is
truth we have the father is truth the
son is truth the holy spirit is truth
and what is the that truth the word of
God my listening friend regardless of
your age it is not acceptable to God
that everyone decides what is truth you
know people do that with the Sabbath
I'll worship on Sunday I'll worship on
Tuesday I'll worship on Wednesday the
truth of God says the Sabbath day God
has decided what is truth and he has put
that information in his holy word if you
want to discover what is truth you go to
the source of Truth Thy word is truth
and it is only by the truth that you're
Sanctified you see Jesus said sanctify
them through thy truth but if you have
one truth I have another he has another
she has another which one has the
sanctifying effect it is that which is
found in the word of God which is the
truth that sanctifies and saves which is
the truth that is personified in the
very life of Jesus Christ
all right thank you for that the the
next question has to do with uh the day
of the week that you worship so the
question is is I don't see any
difference between worshiping on
Saturday or Sunday so why should it
matter what day that I worship on it
matters what day I worship on because it
matters to God you see what matters to
God should matter to me as early as
Genesis chapter 2 let's read from verse
1 thus the heavens and the Earth were
finished and all the host of them and on
the seventh day God ended his work which
he had made and he rested on the seventh
day from all his work which he had made
and God blessed the seventh day and
Sanctified it because that in it he had
rested from all his work which God
created and made as early as Genesis
chapter 2 verses 2-3 we're told three
times that the Sabbath is the seventh
day it is God's day Exodus chapter 20
reading from verse 8 remember the
Sabbath day to keep it holy six days
shall thou labor and do all thy work but
the seventh day is the Sabbath of the
Lord thy God and the reason why I cannot
change it it is not my day it is God's
day and God chose the seventh I have no
authority to tell God he chose
incorrectly the reason why the day
matters is because it matters to God and
God chose the seventh day and that is
Saturday the seventh day is the Sabbath
regardless of how I feel about Wednesday
Thursday or Sunday there's one day God
is blessed one day he's hallowed one day
he Sanctified that is the seventh day
and he's made that clear to Adam and Eve
even before there was sin the seventh
day is the Sabbath this is God's choice
and if God is my God and I obey him I
make his choice my choice I don't offer
recommendations to God I submit to to
the will of God the seventh day is the
Sabbath of the Lord and God has never
ever chosen any other day and will never
choose any other day because he said I
will not alter the thing that is gone
out of my mouth and he said from his
mouth remember the Sabbath day to keep
it holy it is the seventh day back then
now and always will be that's God's will
make God's will your will and your life
will be blessed
the next question though says
the people at the Sunday churches are
nicer than the Saturday churches so why
should I go to a Saturday Church they're
nice here on Sunday oh that made me
smile I don't know how anyone can prove
that people in Sunday churches or
Wednesday churches are nicer than those
inside of churches it's not it is not
based on how nice you are it is based on
what does God say Jesus said in John 6
70 listen carefully this is Jesus
speaking have I not chosen you twelve
one of you is a devil there was a devil
among the disciples his name is well
known Judas Jesus was the pastor of that
early church one of his members was a
devil now if Jesus can have a devil in
his congregation and he was the pastor
surely modern congregations can have
Devils it is not how nice the members
are the reason to choose a church is
what does the church teach and so in
John 6 verse 66 the Bible says from that
time many of his disciples went back and
walked no more with him verse 67 then
said Jesus to the twelve will ye also go
away Peter said in the next verse Lord
to whom shall we go thou Hast the words
of eternal life Peter tells Christ we're
not leaving you were staying why because
of what you're preaching it is the
preaching of truth that should attract
you to the church not how nice the
members are let me repeat Jesus said in
John 6 17 have I not chosen you twelve
one of you is a devil all churches have
well-dressed attractive Devils but that
should not discourage you the reason for
choosing a church is it preach the truth
Jesus taught the truth one member was a
devil do not avoid the Church of God
simply because there are some devilish
people in that church you choose a
church based on what it teaches not on
how nice the members are how lovely the
church looks or how handsome the pastor
is based on thus saith the Lord and if
more people would do that we would not
have tragedies like Jonestown and Waco
Texas where people followed somebody and
they ended up losing their life you
follow thus Seth the Lord
we need to give the climate a break the
climate the climate we need to give the
climate a break is the next question and
since the majority of the world worships
on Sunday why not make a law that
everybody should take off on Sunday we
don't need to give the climate a break
we need to give God a break from all the
Disobedience we inflict upon him that's
whom we need to give a breakthrough to
God we torture god with con continuous
Disobedience and human reasoning that's
the person who needs a break we are
given six days to work one day to rest
if we would follow God's prescription
the climate would be just fine but let
me also say because of sin the climate
will get worse and worse because
anything cursed by sin gradually
deteriorates it may take thousands of
years but let me say it again anything
cursed by sin inevitably deteriorates
over time and so the climate will get
worse and worse that's not a reason to
disregard our environment not at all
because when God made Adam he gave him
dominion over the world he had to take
care of it God made the trees he made
the animals he wants us to care for our
environment but the reason why God will
make a new Heaven and the new earth
Isaiah 65 17 Isaiah 66 verse 22
Revelation 21 verse 1 he has to make a
new Heaven and a new Earth because the
first one and this Heaven and the first
Earth because of sin they are
deteriorating and so it is not whether
we take a day to take care of the
climate if the climate deteriorates or
not we are to observe the sabbath of the
Lord and that day I say is the seventh
day not Sunday the first let me be bold
but respectful the first day of the week
has never been the Sabbath of God now it
is very nice we want to honor the
resurrection of God God that's fine he
does not call us to do that by observing
a day we honor his resurrection by the
foot washing ceremony or I should say
the uh the supper you see where he said
as offers you do this you just show the
Lord's death until he come you want to
honor you want to do something for the
climate obey God and obedience has
benefits across the spectrum of
existence so anyone who sets aside
Sunday as a day to honor the the climate
is acting in violation of God's word God
has given us one day regardless of the
climate because when God gave that day
there were no climate issues and that
day is the seventh day of the week
Saturday the Sabbath let us give God a
Break by ceasing all our Disobedience
the problem is not the climate the
problem is continual sin against God
through disobedience
hmm
the next question
many of the religious world and probably
a lot of the non-religious world has
heard of something called The Mark of
the Beast there's the number 666 that
kind of thing so the question is is what
really is the mark of the beast in order
to answer the question a very simple way
the Beast is opposed to God
you follow me
identify the mark of God
and you can reasonably identify the mark
of the beast now the Bible tells us in
Exodus 31 verse 13 in Ezekiel 20 verse
12 and 20 verse 20 that I have given
them my Sabbath to be a sign between
them and me God has said the sign or the
mark because in the Hebrew sign Mark
talking are all translations of the same
word so God has a mark God has a sign
God has a token that is the seventh day
Sabbath God has said I have given it as
a sign that you're my people it's a sign
between God and his people not God in
the whole world between God and his
people those who choose to obey God the
mark of the beast and this you find this
in a Catholic literature Sunday they say
is the mark of their Authority because
the church said it has the authority to
change the law of God
Sunday observance is theoretically the
mark of the beast why do I say
theoretically because until now there is
no legal requirement to observe Sunday
as a day of worship and so Sunday is
theoretically the mark of the beast when
a law is passed requiring Sunday as the
day of worship those who obey that law
will then have the mark of the beast
because they would have chosen to obey
man instead of God the mark of God is
the serve of their Sabbath The Mark of
the Beast is the observance of any other
day beside the seven of their Sabbath
and the most popular day that competes
with the Sabbath is Sunday
so the mark of the beasts you've
identified but who then is the Beast the
Beast yeah okay now you're getting me
into trouble but that's good it's okay
if you look at the writings of all the
reformers go back as far as even before
the reformers now the Beast that my
brothers refer or you're referring to is
uh mentioned in Revelation 13. under the
leopard-like Beast that Beast is
mentioned in Daniel 7 and it is called
uh the the the the the horn the little
horn it's also mentioned in second
Thessalonians 2 called the man of sin so
it has all these there essentially it is
a power that opposes God
it is a religious system that opposes
God that's what makes it so astonishing
that most of the world have not
recognized the Beast because no one
expects a religious organization to
oppose God you see it is astonishing not
a church opposing God but the Beast is a
religious organization and careful study
of the Bible will show you that the
Beast is the papal system this has been
discovered by Bible study by Luther by
Calvin by the Wesley Brothers by Knox
you go back and study the history they
have all identified the papal system as
the Beast it is that system that
legalized Sunday as the day of worship
and criminalize Sabbath keeping the
Beast is the people's system I did not
say the Beast refers to ordinary members
in the Pew I am saying the Beast is that
people system that purports claims to
have the authority to change God's law
and that conclusion has been was arrived
at hundreds of hundreds of years ago as
a matter of fact that system at one
point even banned the Bible you could
lose your life by having a Bible it was
not the government who did that it was a
religious system I say again it was a
religious system that said crucify Jesus
Christ the Romans said let him go the
secular power said let him go a
religious system said kill him let me
say again to you my listening friend the
beast power mentioned in Revelation 13
Daniel 7 2 Thessalonians 2 is the
religious system and bible study will
show you that system is the papal system
or the Roman system
are we really living in the time of the
end or is this just an era that we're
going through
we are living in the time of the end now
if you read Matthew 24 Luke 21 and Mark
13 you'll find all the signs that point
to the fact that Christ is soon to come
yes we're living in the time of the end
now that's a question that requires a
lot of time to really fully answer but
if you study Matthew 24 Luke 21 and in
Mark 13 you will quickly realize that we
are indeed living in the time of the end
and it is a very serious time because
Christ is soon to come and when Christ
comes he's not coming to provide
additional probation within which people
can make decisions to obey him when
Christ comes he is not coming as a
priest he is coming as a king in the
Jewish system the priest when he
functioned he wore a miter on his head
you read that in Leviticus 16 verse 4
when Christ comes he is not wearing a
miter he's wearing a crown Revelation 14
verse 14. the crowns suggests he's
coming as a conquering King when Christ
comes there's no more opportunity to
repent many churches teach when he comes
there'll be some time to repent that is
absolutely destructive teaching when
Jesus Christ comes back he's coming back
because his work of saving people has
been finished and so he comes back to
destroy his enemies and take his people
with him yes we are living in the end of
time and my appeal to you is to consider
this our present life is about this long
that's it
eternal life is this
if this is all this life is and this is
eternal life where should your emphasis
be on this or on this Common Sense
should tell us my focus should be
preparing for this not necessarily
ignoring this but prioritizing this we
are living in the end time and the final
events that literally bring Christ down
from heaven will be threatened there
will be sudden there will be
catastrophic but they will come and if
we're not prepared day by day when those
events occur we will never be prepared
we are living in the last days and
Christ is soon to come my listening
friend get ready for his coming and when
I say get ready continually surrender to
him that he might make you ready for his
return but yes we're living absolutely
in the last days
the next question kind of goes back to
the issue of death
and it's kind of a three-fold question
the the first part of that is what does
the Bible say about committing suicide
uh can a person be saved if they commit
suicide and more specifically will a
Believer a Christian who commits suicide
be saved
that's a delicate question
your life does not belong to you
First Corinthians 6 19 20 he bought with
a price ye and not your own no one is
authorized to take his or her life
people say well look at Samson Samson
did not take his life Samson sacrificed
his life those are two different things
when soldiers go to war they are not
committing suicide they are sacrificing
themselves Jesus Christ did not commit
suicide but he laid down his own life he
tells us in John chapter 10 verse 18 no
man taketh it from me I lay down of
myself I have power to lay down I have
power to take it up again Christ
sacrifice himself that was not suicide
suicide is a crime against God and
against mankind Christ did not commit
suicide he sacrificed his life Samson
did not commit suicide Samson sacrifices
life you read the book of Acts chapter
20 verse 22 to 24 Paul knew that by
going to Jerusalem he would die but he
went because he had been given a mission
from God that was not suicide that is a
willingness to sacrifice the life for
the cause of God the three Hebrew boys
willingly went into the burning fiery
furnace why do I say willingly the men
taking them fell down dead so they must
have walked into that furnace that was
not suicide we know that God saved them
but had he not saved them it would not
have been suicide let me tell you again
your life does not belong to you it
belongs to God and to commit suicide is
to deliberately knowingly intentionally
take from God what is his so I do not
see how someone who deliberately commits
suicide can be saved notice I said I
don't see how and I don't claim to know
everything let me say again Christ did
not commit suicide he gave up his life
for the glory of the father Samson did
not commit suicide he gave of his life
for the glory of the purpose of his God
the god of the Israel Samson is in
Hebrews 11 in the Hall of faith and so
he will be saved suicide is taking the
life not for the glory of God but for
one's own purposes and so all I can say
is I do not see how someone who commits
suicide can be saved I just don't see
how that's the limit of my wisdom on
that question
there are many books out there in the
world and how do I know if the Bible is
the only book that I should use for a
source of inspiration and guidance can I
use other books for my inspiration and
my guidance
I like that question as Christians we
ought not to be narrow-minded God has
not given all wisdom only to Christians
there are some non-christians to whom
God has seen fit to reveal information
that the Christian may not have
let me use this example the Bible is the
Bible as a book of Prophecy the seven of
the Adventist Church of which I am a
member it is founded on Prophecy and the
prophetic statement that's the
Cornerstone of our religion or our
teaching is Daniel 8 14 under 2 300 days
then shall the sanctuary be cleansed but
if you take a prophecy as occurs in
Daniel 2 Daniel saw an image the head of
gold the Rebellion the belly the breasts
and arms of silver the belly of of a
legs of the belly of um brass and the
legs of iron they represented Nations
Babylon
little Persia Greece and Rome you've got
to go to secular history to establish
the accuracy of that if you go to Daniel
8 we have the the goat with the notable
horn we have the ram the battle between
the RAM and the Goat the goat destroys
the ram that's Greece destroying the
Persians which actually happened but
you've got to go to secular history to
determine that and so prophecy which is
history spoken in advance
you must study secular history so that
you can see the accuracy of Bible
prophecy I am saying all of that to say
yes there is some factual information to
be found outside of the Bible yes but in
general saving truth is found here let
me say it again there is truth which
means something is factual Tuesday comes
before Wednesday that is a fact that is
true that is not saving truth are you
calling me rain falls down it does not
fall up that is true that is not saving
truth but if we confess our sins he's
faithful and just to forgive us our sins
that is saving truth saving truth is
found in the word of God that is why
Jesus said man shall not live by bread
alone but by every word that proceedeth
out of the mouth of God and by the way
when he said that he was referring to
the Ten Commandments I don't have the
time to show that to you but when Jesus
said man shall not live by bread alone
but by every word the proceedeth out of
the mouth of God he was actually
referring to the Ten Commandments as the
way of life God has revealed information
to a lot of people a lot of scientists
to archaeologists and that information
has supported the fact that the Bible is
the word of God but if you want saving
truth if you want truth that sanctifies
and according to first Thessalonians 4 3
this is the will of God even your
sanctification the truth that does that
is the truth that is found in the pages
of this book called The Holy Bible and I
recommend that book to you with all my
heart and soul it will change your life
it will change your thinking it will
change your children it will improve
your health because the word of God the
truth of God is life
and the Bible also reveals in his word
in the word that the first miracle of
Christ
was that he changed water into wine in
the in the in that wedding so the
question is is is is it then okay for a
Christian to drink wine
the word wine has a certain emotional
effect you see we think of alcohol
the juice of the grape is referred to
the Bible as wine grape juice is wine
but when we hear wine we hear
intoxicating beverage God cannot talk
from both sides of his mouth if you
study the Bible carefully the very first
reference to wine is in Genesis 9. and
Noah planted a Vini began to be a
husband man and he planted a Vineyard
and he drank of the wine and was drunken
in his tent now this is our introduction
to alcohol you see he became drunk his
younger son did something to him that's
not explain in the Bible and no accuracy
and we know that story The the second
introduction to wine is in Genesis 14
where melchized bread forth Bread and
Wine he was a priest of the most high
God the third introduction to wine is
Genesis 19 where lot's two daughters
gave him wine to drink made him drunk
grape juice does not make you drunk that
is what the Bible condemns intoxicating
beverages not grape juice Jesus Christ
who is God G Jesus Christ was the word
cannot condemn intoxicating Beverages
and then give it to people he does not
do that because the Bible calls us to
live what we preach and so where you
read wine that's intoxicating referring
to alcohol but the one that Christ made
when he converted water into wine was
not intoxicating beverage it was the
fruit the juice of the grape which was
grape juice not something that makes you
drunk
God does not sanction alcoholic
intoxicating beverages he does not do
that because we're not to defile this
body when wine was offered to Daniel and
his three Hebrew friends hananiah
Michelle Azariah in Daniel 1 they
refused it because they did not want to
defile their bodies then that wine was
alcohol grape juice does not defile
alcohol defiles so when you see wine in
the Bible you've got to be careful is it
referring to the intoxicating beverage
or is it referring to the juice of the
grape what God recommends is the juice
of the Great
the next question has to do with
marriage and actually in this case
divorce and the question is
should a person be allowed to divorce
another in the case of abuse whether it
be physical mental or emotional
and another part of that is why does the
bible only really outline adultery as
the reason that a person can divorce
okay it's a serious question and a
sensitive one
marriage is an extremely serious choice
people get in and out of marriages as
though it's a recreational activity
marriage is Serious Business from God's
Viewpoint once you're in you're in but
God allows one clear cause for divorce
and that is adultery one clear cause for
divorce adultery now churches may give
you other avenues to divorce the Bible
gives one clear reason for divorce that
is adultery where you've broken that
contract between you and the other
person
now
there's causes for separation
but separation is not diverse
there are causes for separation now if a
woman or man is being abused the person
may choose to separate after having done
what he or she could do to heal that
situation the Bible tells us in Romans
12 verse 18 if it be possible as much as
life in you live peaceably with all men
including your spouse Who's acting up if
that concentrated effort fails you may
separate but the reason for divorce is
adultery and this may sound harsh but
this is biblical and so let me say again
before you get into marriage please keep
in mind once you're in biblically you
are in and the only clear cause for
divorce is adultery now the question is
why would God only give that I don't
know that's the only one God gives as a
matter of fact when we leave God he
calls that adultery
spiritual adultery or spiritual
fornication and so he applies it at the
social level adultery is the clear and I
keep saying the clear biblical
foundation for separation or divorce but
even then he Malachi chapter 2 verse 16
God does not like divorce you see he
prefers reconciliation that's why it is
a cross of Calvary to bring about
reconciliation between God and the
people who divorce him that is Sinners
when God drove Adam out of the garden
the Hebrew word technically means
divorce but he sent Christ to bring him
back and so the force is allowed based
on adultery the clear biblical justice
Bible justification
separation is allowed if a woman is
being beaten up or a man separation is
fine but keep in mind separation does
not free you to remarry separation is
not divorce
adultery is the clear Bible reason for
divorce
the next question is is it a sin to
worry
very carefully I'll say this
if God tells me
don't do something
and I do it I have sinned
the Bible tells us over and over don't
worry Don't Fear take no thoughts for
tomorrow
to worry is to tell God I am questioning
your ability to handle a situation
understand this about God God put
everything in place before he made Adam
and Eve when Adam and Eve opened their
eyes they had water they had food they
had shelter they had the right
environment they had a companionship of
animals of one another they had
everything necessary for a blessed life
that's the way God functions so we learn
from Genesis 1 the creation story that
our God puts things in place all we need
to do is obey him when God brought the
Israelites Into the Wilderness he
deliberately took them into the
Wilderness one reason was to show them
he can take care of them Jesus says take
no thought for the morrow the reason why
we worry I believe fundamentally is that
from time to time we remove God from
position one in our lives and when God
is no longer in position one whatever is
in position one then becomes a temporary
source of sustenance and then we have to
worry because we realize that thing is
not sufficient when God stays as number
one then it gives us the courage we need
even though we cannot see the way out
when in John chapter 6 Jesus told Philip
when shall we buy bread that these made
the feeling of the five thousand now
Philip had no clue what he would do but
the Bible says Jesus knew what he would
do Christ already had the answer but he
tested Philip and the other disciples we
serve a God who has all our needs
covered whether we can see that or not
and so to worry is in a certain sense to
question God but a relationship with God
is a growth second Peter chapter 3 verse
18 but grow in Grace and in the
knowledge of our Lord and Savior Jesus
Christ as we get to know God through
study of the word and Obedience of the
word as we learn of God we worry less
and less and less because it is a
growing process but nowhere in the Bible
are we told to worry we're told not to
worry and so in that sense worrying is a
sin but God understands we're weak and
the Lord takes us along step by step but
if your focus is God the God who made
Heaven and Earth The God Who made trees
for food he made water to drink The God
Who did that can take care of me the
problem is am I fully surrendered to God
and if I'm totally surrendered to God my
problems become his problems little
children don't worry
they leave that to the parents we must
have that attitude with God
how about the next question
is once saved always saved truly
biblical it is absolutely not biblical
go ahead and can a Christian
uh lose his salvation yes a Christian
can lose his salvation right from the
mouth of Jesus Christ himself John 17
verse 12 Jesus said in a prayer while I
was with them in the world I kept them
in thy name Those whom thou give us me I
have kept and none of them is lost but
the Son of Perdition that the scripture
might be fulfilled Jesus said Judas was
lost and Judas was chosen by Christ he
was one of the twelve when Christ gave
them power to cast out devils and do
Miracles Judas was included but Jesus
was lost Paul said dmas hath forsaken me
having loved this present world and has
departed unto thessalonica dmas used to
work with Paul then he left Paul and
went off into the world there is no such
thing in the Bible as once saved always
saved you can be saved and decide at
some point to leave God this was the
case with Judas this was the case with
dmas not everyone who comes to God stays
with God in John chapter 6 verse 66 from
that time many of his disciples went
back and walked normal with him they
were lost they were with him then they
left him the Bible does not teach one
saved always saved now it's attracted to
the carnal nature because if I say I
come to Jesus today Thursday he saves me
then I cannot be lost so I go to the bar
go to the casino go to the whorehouse go
to the drug deal I cannot be lost you
see so it Comforts The Sinner the one
who loves to practice sin to believe
once they've always saved but no no no
no no when you're saved you've got to
hold on to Jesus to preserve that state
of justice of being justified the Bible
talks about sanctification continual
growth a safe person can decide to leave
God their biblical examples one saved
always say is a satanic Doctrine
let me repeat my words it is a satanic
Doctrine it is not in the Bible
you know Adam
we read in Genesis that Adam sinned
so if Adam sinned why is God concerned
about the rest of Adam's children us the
rest of his family why should we have to
be involved in this doesn't seem fair if
Adam's sin then it should be between God
and Adam why is it also affecting us
no one is born guilty of Adam's sin
you're responsible for the sin you're
responsible for the sins you commit you
see the sun shall not perish for the
father's sins or the father for the son
sins we are born in a condition that
requires a savior
let me say differently everyone born
into the world of Adam is born needing a
savior
no one is born guilty of Adam's sin
because none of us chose to commit his
sin but the way God said of the system
the behavior of one can affect others
now when Jesus Christ died who is the
second Adam he provided a covering for
every person who's ever been born and
that is called probation it was the
blood of Christ that prevented Adam from
dying immediately it was the blood of
Christ because he was the lamb slain
from the foundation of the world let me
say again when Christ died his blood
covered the entire world like the
morning and evening sacrifice in the
days of the Old Testament you see now
that covering didn't mean salvation from
sin it meant a temporary protection from
destruction from condemnation within
which period you can come to him and be
justified let me say that again
differently when Adam and Eve sinned and
they hid from God they were lost
they were lost
Christ came to save them but they were
lost with hope and that hope was because
of the blood of Christ when Jesus said
to Zacchaeus the son of man is come to
seek and to save that which was lost
that seeking began in Eden he came to
seek Adam and Eve to save them remember
they were hiding from him no saved
person hides from God so Adam and Eve
were lost but they were lost under the
hope of the blood of Christ and so they
came and the father of Christ saved them
by covering them with the courts of skin
the sin of Adam gave to us a nature that
leans towards sin we have to be saved
from that so everyone born of Adam and
Eve comes into the world needing a
savior but not guilty of Adam's sin let
me say that clearly that's original sin
where the Bible does not teach that but
you were born in need of a savior the
only person who was not born in need of
a savior was the Savior himself Jesus
Christ that is the part of the mystery
of the Incarnation Christ becoming human
and so God does not hold me guilty for
what Adam did god holds me responsible
for the choices I make
thank you Elder skeet my pleasure these
These are the last of our the questions
that we have for today
um could you wrap this up and address
um our audience what what if they have
other questions where should they go for
their source of answers
my friend Wherever You Are
if you have a Bible question go to the
Bible
the Bible is a source of unerring Truth
when Christ was tempted by the devil in
Matthew chapter 4 Luke chapter 4 in
Matthew's version
Matthew 4 verse 4 Christ said to the
devil man shall not live by bread alone
but by every word that proceedeth out of
the mouth of God
in Psalm 119 verse 105 the Bible says
Thy word is a lamp unto my feet and a
light unto my path the word of God tells
us how to live in many ways the Bible is
a how-to book how to raise your children
how to manage your finances how to
conquer sin how to prepare for the life
to come how to detect error how to
whatever the Bible is a manual of how to
live a life that pleases God and so if
you have questions now let me also say
there are some people who are blessed by
God with Bible knowledge and yes you may
talk to them it may be your pastor it
may be whomever but that does not remove
from you the serious responsibility to
make an attempt to understand the word
of God because Jesus gave you a promise
in John 16 verse 13 how be it when he
the spirit of Truth has come he will
guide you into all truth I want you to
believe that if you take your Bible in
your hand and you say father Teach Me
Guide Me God will do that but there are
conditions for understanding the word of
God condition one get rid of Sin Sin
creates static that blocks the
transmission of truth from Heaven two
you must be willing to obey what you
learn John 7 verse 17
If any man will do his will he shall
know the doctrine a willingness to obey
is essential for God to reveal Truth
David prayed in Psalm 119 verse 18 open
thou mine eyes that I may behold
wondrous things out of thy law ask God
to explain the word to you make an
effort to study confess your sins and
ask the holy spirit of God to guide you
never never give up the privilege of
studying the Bible for yourself because
when you study the Bible you are
fellowshipping with father son Holy
Ghost and Angels why why do I say that
in the book of Acts chapter 8 an angel
told Philip to go down the road that led
to a certain direction then Philip began
to walk that road when Philip got near
to The Chariot the Holy Spirit told him
go up to the Chariot and so we have two
Heavenly beings the angel told him the
road to take the spirit told him go up
to the Chariot and so we have the spirit
and the angel involved in a teaching
experience where Philip taught the
Ethiopian unit and so when you study the
word of God Jesus says I am the truth
the father is truth Deuteronomy 32 verse
4 the holy spirit is truth first John 5
Verse 6 when you study the word of God
you are fellowshipping with father son
Holy Spirit and Angels when Daniel was
given a vision in Daniel chapter 8 verse
16 the Bible says Daniel Heard a Voice
between the banks of Uli which called
and said Gabriel make this man to
understand the vision Gabriel was
commanded by God to help Daniel will
understand when you study the Bible
father son Holy Spirit and angels are
all involved in that activity and so I
urge you yes there may be some things
you won't understand you may need to ask
your pastor but never never absolutely
surrender the privilege of Bible study
because Bible study is fellowship with
the family of heaven and if your desire
is to know what is true God will reveal
it and when he does obey him may the
Lord bless you and put a double blessing
on your children amen
thank you so much Elder ski my pleasure
we appreciate you being here and
answering all these questions all right
and uh we look forward to doing this
again in the future may God bless you
and thank you for watching
[Music]
it stands
till I come